[Music]
New York just like lets you be who you
are is my shoulder out
I mean we are all friends and so there's
always some version of like
hate against one other people are Petty
people get mad for stupid reasons and
they blow them into Epic Proportions I
knew with me however you know being a
good Canadian I'm I'm always kind of a
neutral party and I I don't really like
to like dip my tattooed bar into the
drama but when it comes to drama the
name Dorothy comes to mind for me she is
negative what a waste of time this woman
is I don't have competition I'm ready
for the fight sometimes I don't want to
have to unleash but like I will she
loves the drama she's extremely
outspoken
um yeah she's she's a funny one I love
that girl Dorothy was actually really
great at like supporting us throughout
the filming of the show she knew what to
do what not to do what we could get away
with what we couldn't get away with I'm
a Scorpio so I don't really like to
share myself super publicly generally so
like just the idea of being on a show
where I'm playing myself was definitely
nerve-wracking now tell me this if you
have any cast member from the OG the
original blink Empire join the cast of
bling Empire New York who would it be
and why well I'm gonna say this I say
this all the time I am 100 team Anna she
is amazing uh we hung out I make a
little cameo in uh LA's last season when
she comes to New York and we go to
fashion shows together and she's amazing
she's incredibly generous and I think
um she's kind of the same age as my mom
so she can't be consisting you know
these mom energies which is really nice
I love her yeah what do you say to
people out there who have a perception
of anyone on this show that maybe you're
just a bunch of spoiled rich kids
over 145 carats this is like three year
Rolls Royce 16 months this is supposed
to be an Escapist comedy
this is supposed to be something you
watch and you kind of get out of your
normal life I like it when it's like
stuffed do you
some of us and I think in particular
with New York what we really want to
show is that we all work we have all
work to get to the places we are I think
in that way we hope that this is kind of
inspiring and honestly like
for me it has nothing to do with money
you know my bling is the idea the fact
that like I'm a cultural guy like I have
an incredible group of friends and like
go to Art parties and go to Fashion
things and that's my blame
[Music]
[Laughter]